welcome back to Las Vegas now alloy
personal training the sponsors of this
segment has opened a new location for
their Community to get ready for summer
and achieve their fitness goals we
stopped by to learn more about their
small group personal training Style
[Music]
welcome back to alloy personal training
I'm Anna the regional director here in
Las Vegas we are so excited to announce
the opening of our second location here
in South Las Vegas last year we opened
our first one and since then we have
over a hundred locations purchased
around the country and 50 will be open
by the end of the year here at alloy we
do small group personal training we give
everybody a customized program we start
with what we call a starting point
session where we'll talk about your
goals your Fitness history we'll do a
movement assessment to see where you're
at how you're currently moving if you
have any imbalances or any limited range
of motion we'll also get you on our in
body to show more about your body
composition with all of this information
we'll also will also provide some
nutritional coaching that's what makes
this different from other Boutique
studios around town we hold our members
accountable and will help guide you each
step of the way so we're going to learn
learn how to dead lift the Kettlebell
from the floor we want to hinge at the
hips so first you want to push your hips
back breaking at the hips first keeping
the knees over the ankles you're going
to grab your weight pack your shoulders
down and back make sure your core is
fully engaged now you're going to push
through those Heels come up squeeze the
glutes making sure that you've kept your
core engaged the entire time so we work
with all Fitness levels in all age
groups matter of fact we work with many
members who are 50 60s and up who have
never worked out before and who are
achieving great results this is super
important because as we get older we do
lose muscle mass especially if you're
not actively strength training we
incorporate a lot of these Step Boards
into our exercises this is where we're
challenging our members to improve their
stability so we'll do exercises like
this or we're just tapping with their
toes
we'll also be stepping over the board
and all these things will help someone
actually improve their stability so this
is a perfect time to open this new
location because we're walking right
into summer and I'm sure many of you
that have fitness goals that you'd like
to work on so along with your personal
training sessions here you would also
get nutritional coaching weekend
workshops and challenges that would help
boost your progress toward your fitness
goals we provide a results-based fitness
program where we're getting our members
on the embody machine at least once a
month to track their progress we're
looking at numbers that truly Define
where they are in their fitness journey
and you know along with that we're
providing accountability and we are
growing this strong community of people
who have goals that they're working
toward want to age graciously and you
know we've been stronger together since
1992.
we want to thank alloy personal training
for sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at
702-500-0362 or visit their website at
alloypersonaltraining.com and they have
a special offer of 50 off for your first
month